okay um
i'm gonna do another video in english
and um we got a sicilian again
the opponent is called a postmortem
from france
yeah it's gone for the c4 line
well i must admit that i don't know um
this opening very well or maybe you can
say
i don't know it at all but it's um
interesting to try out
i'd like to exchange the ducks for a
bishop here because it's uh
at least theoretically the bad bishop
for black and now i got a pretty
solid structure here for the fine bishop
only six
well the e2 bishop is um
not very active at the moment and can be
a problem in the end game
i'm still very far away from an endgame
so
it's um not a big issue right now
yeah i go i go knight d4 because it's a
nice square anyway and
i guess it helps a little bit to
also cover the d6 pawn
yes gun bishop d3
yeah i'm not i'm not sure about this
position
is it an idea to play b5 here
we could he could take two times on b5
but then i will get
the e4 pawn
but this also could be a weakness
if it just takes and plays some
quiet move like a3 or b4 before
i think i go for it it's not entirely
clear for sure but
it's um i think something i can only do
at this point
otherwise he might prevent it
hmm i'm not sure maybe maybe he really
needs to take on b5
some quiet moves won't give white
anything i guess
like this one
i could even think of b4 here
where will he put the knight then to a4
looks ridiculous
i go if i go b4
that e2 i could simply um take
and also a2 is this is just hanging
around
in mid-air so
it looks like a really decent position
for black
of course you can also go to d5 but
then i'll i'll just take this knight and
i will have no problems at all in the
future with
the square d5 yeah he's gone for this
so interesting now with the naido or
with the bishop
i pre actually prefer to take with the
bishop here
after e takes d5 you also
can't easily switch the knight to c4
because d5 is hanging
yeah but now i'm interesting
i could go queen a5
then he could could play a knight to c4
i could simply
play queen to b6 yeah yeah knight c4 is
always an issue
still queen a5 looks looks like
a good active move as d5 is saying a2 is
hanging
and on a3 i even have the possibility to
to go um knight b3 i think
and knight c4 i can also simply take on
a2
yeah i can i can take on d6 but
d5 is also hanging so i could exchange
on c1 and take d5
interesting
yeah well that's surprising well maybe
he just wants to play for the week um
back rank with rook c1 right now
i didn't um take that into account at
all
not sure if it's really dangerous or or
anything but
i didn't i didn't think of this idea
it will maybe just just take now and
then go g6
to protect the back rank and
still still those two pawns are
hanging
besides the potential problem of a
past pawn here on the queen side um
i just have a very nice structure with
the two good knights
and the weaknesses on a2 and d5
yes was the
um the passive option
white of course always had
yeah maybe maybe he really intends to go
a3
but uh i like to
to centralize the knight here
maybe with f5 to come later or
just put it on c5 which is also a nice
square
and this is really not a pleasant
position to play for white
i guess yeah he intends a3 i think
maybe just just queen c5 to to
step away from the a3 thread
yeah interesting
can i go f5 or is this too loose
yeah i like this move it's it's makes a
very active impression
yeah no not just
some strength strengthening moves around
the king
yeah i think he wants to wants to go
queen a4 at some point
can i play f4
time warning i'm not sure
yeah i like the idea to to keep an eye
on
f2 uh-huh
but then i can and just take a e3 and f2
i think
this must be must be okay
okay
knight f5
why do i have some really strong move
all right i'm not sure
i guess this forces him to take as he
just did
and now i can can pick up pawns
at least okay he's got some
ideas of a perpetual check but check
i now can exchange queens yeah
this should should be enough
check
white forfeits on time
yeah yeah i guess it was was quite a
decent game i think
i got a good position after v5 with a
very strong knight on on d4 which was
always
a real nuisance for why to to play
around
and uh at the end he's he really got
problems with the
passive position of the bishop and d3
and also the weaknesses on d5 and a2
yep